At one level, my Grandma Frieda's college records are utterly ordinary-- don't tell much of a story. She's a good student, and teachers say the nice things that they say about bright students. They talk about her sense of social responsibility. They talk about her, quote, excellent and well-trained mind. This is 1931, that they would say such a thing. Goucher College, then an all girls' school in Baltimore.
从某种程度上讲，我祖母弗里达的大学档案非常普通——讲不出什么故事来。她是个好学生，老师们对她做出的评价也是老师们通常会给聪明学生的好评。他们提到她的社会责任感。他们说她拥有“极其出色且训练有素的头脑”，这可是1931年，当时人们竟然会这样评价。高彻学院，当时巴尔的摩的一所全女子学校。
I got these records a few years back when I was invited to give a commencement address at Goucher. I asked if I could get a copy of her school records. And there's such a different picture of this person I knew. It's my grandma as a college kid. Grandma Frieda was training to be a teacher, and her evaluations say that she has a lot of promise.
几年前，我受邀在高彻学院发表毕业典礼演讲时拿到了这些档案。我问是否可以拿到一份她的学籍记录复印件。档案中呈现出的那个我所认识的人，有着截然不同的形象。那是身为大学生的祖母。祖母弗里达当时正在接受教师培训，她的评估报告说她很有前途。
Quote, "She did her practice teaching with great success, making unusually varied, interesting, and well organized lesson plans, presenting her material with force and vigor, showing great accuracy in all details." I like that one. "She has a forceful as well as a very pleasant personality," which I can say is true. She is very smart, always let you know what she thought.
原文写道：“她圆满完成了实习教学，制定了非常多样化、有趣且条理清晰的教案，讲解内容充满力量与活力，细节处理十分精准。”我喜欢这一条。“她既有强有力的个性，又非常讨人喜欢，”这一点我可以证实是真的。她非常聪明，总是让你知道她的想法。
There's four of these evaluations. They list her traits. There's like a checklist with some energy, reliability, perseverance, resourcefulness. She's 21 years old, poised on the verge of a great future, which is what is so hard about reading these things today. It's a future she never got to live.
这种评估表共有四份，上面列出了她的特质。有一个类似检查清单的项目，包括精力、可靠性、毅力和足智多谋。她那时21岁，正处于美好未来的边缘，这也是今天阅读这些东西时最让人难受的地方。那是她从未能真正过上的未来。
It's not a pleasurable thing to read.
阅读这些内容不是一件让人愉快的事情。
Well, she had a lot of potential, but I don't think it really got realized.
她确实很有潜力，但我觉得她并没有真正实现那些潜力。
Those are two kids, my dad and my uncle, Barry and Lenny, now in their 80s. I asked them to read through this stuff and talk to me about it. And there were so many things that stopped her from realizing her potential. After she graduated, Frieda taught junior high school for a year and then she married and very quickly, like amazingly quickly, her marriage fell apart.
那两个孩子是我爸和我叔叔，巴里和兰尼，现在都已经80多岁了。我让他们读了这些资料并跟我谈了谈。有太多事情阻碍了她实现自己的潜力。毕业后，弗里达在初中教了一年书，然后结婚了，但非常快，快得令人惊讶，她的婚姻就破裂了。
By her late 20s, she was a single mom with two kids. This is back in the 1930s. This is during the depression. And to help support her whole extended family, she apparently got drafted to work in the family business, which was this little corner grocery store in downtown Baltimore where they lived.
到20多岁末期，她成了一位带着两个孩子的单身母亲。那是在20世纪30年代，正值经济大萧条时期。为了帮衬整个大家庭，她显然被征召去经营家族生意，也就是他们居住的巴尔的摩市中心那家小杂货店。
Yeah, it was a drag. And it was dragging her down.
没错，那是个累赘，而且一直在拖累她。
Did she talk about wanting to teach during those years when she was running the store?
她在经营店铺的那些年里，有没有说过想回去教书？
Yes.
说过。
Yeah.
是啊。
And when did you guys start to work in the store?
你们俩是什么时候开始在那家店里帮忙的？
Oh, we always did, from the time we were a little kids.
噢，我们一直都在帮忙，从我们还是小孩的时候起就是这样。
Yeah, we always did.
没错，我们一直都在做。
Like, you were like, five or six years old and you're working in the store?
也就是说，你们五六岁的时候就在店里干活了？
Yep. Well, seven or eight.
是的。大概七八岁吧。
What would you do?
你们做什么呢？
Stock the shelves, open up--
理货，开门——
Yeah, stocking.
对，理货。
Even wait on people, I think, as I remember.
我记得甚至还要招待客人。
Frieda's parents and other relatives lived above and next door to the store. It was run by Frieda's dad, Isidore. He was kind of a soft touch and would lose a lot of money by extending credit to customers who'd never pay it back. I'm named for Isidore. I have his Hebrew name, Yitzchak.
弗里达的父母和其他亲戚住在店的楼上和隔壁。店是由弗里达的父亲伊西多尔经营的。他是个心软的人，总是因为给那些永远不会还钱的顾客赊账而亏损。我是以伊西多尔的名字命名的。我有他那样的希伯来名字，伊茨哈克。
They didn't name me Isidore because they realized at some point that Isidore Glass is a parsable sentence in English, is a door glass. Also, I was told years ago by my mom that they wanted a name that was less Jew-y. The fact that with that mission they ended up at Ira just shows how little the whole family knew about the world of non-Jews at the time.
他们没给我取名伊西多尔，因为他们后来意识到在英语里“伊西多尔·格拉斯”听起来像是一个能拆解的句子——“是一扇门玻璃”。而且，我妈妈多年前告诉我，他们想要一个听起来不那么“犹太味”的名字。事实上，带着这种使命他们最终选择了“艾拉”，这足以说明当时整个家族对非犹太人的世界了解得有多么少。
Anyway, Frieda's college file also includes all the alumni questionnaires that she sent into Goucher in the decades after she graduated. And in those, in the formal language of somebody filling out a form, she describes first helping in the store in the 1930s-- doing the books, waiting on customers, bringing her kids to help work-- and then finally taking the store over when her dad got sick in 1950, trying to keep the store afloat as it slowly went bankrupt. There was another thing that shaped her life in ways that nobody could foresee back when she was 21, getting those glowing evaluations from her teachers.
总之，弗里达的大学档案里还包括她在毕业后的几十年里发给高彻学院的所有校友问卷。在那些问卷中，她用填写表格的人所惯用的正式语言，描述了她从20世纪30年代开始在店里帮忙——记账、接待顾客、带着孩子一起工作——最后在1950年她父亲生病时接管了店铺，并试图在店铺慢慢倒闭的过程中维持经营。还有另一件事，以一种当年她21岁时从老师那里获得极高评价时任何人都无法预见的方式，重塑了她的人生。
Her health affliction was the dominating component of her life, and determined a lot of what eventually happened to her. I don't know how much you know, Ira, about how she got cancer.
她的健康状况是她生命中最具支配性的部分，并决定了她后来发生的许多事情。艾拉，我不知道你对她是如何患上癌症的了解多少。
Actually, I know that story well. When she was a teenager, Frieda got acne. And the doctor treated it-- this is the early 1920s-- with this new miracle treatment, x-rays. He bombarded her face with x-rays. Nobody would do this today, because we now understand that gives you cancer, and that's exactly what it did to her.
其实，我很了解那个故事。弗里达十几岁时患上了痤疮。医生给她进行了治疗——那是20世纪20年代初——用的是一种新的神奇疗法：X射线。他用X射线轰击她的脸。今天没有人会这么做了，因为我们现在明白那会导致癌症，而这正是它带给她的结果。
She got skin cancer when she was 32, which back then, doctors had a hard time treating. Uncle Lenny, I should say, as a doctor who was also her kid, remembers chapter and verse of all the operations and procedures and what went wrong and how it would recur. And it just, it slowly took over most of her face and her nose.
她在32岁时患上了皮肤癌，在那时，医生很难治疗这种病。兰尼叔叔，我得说，作为一名医生同时也是她的孩子，他记得每一场手术和治疗的细节，以及哪里出了问题，还有癌症是如何复发的。这慢慢地占据了她大部分的脸部和鼻子。
Well, eventually that became something which is never seen today, which is called a rodent ulcer. It got that name because it looked as though some rodent had eaten someone's face away.
最终，那变成了一种在今天几乎看不见的东西，叫做“啮蚀性溃疡”。之所以得名，是因为它看起来就像是被某种啮齿动物啃掉了脸。
How many surgeries did she have on her face, Lenny?
兰尼，她脸上动过多少次手术？
Oh, god, I would say-- 25 or 30.
天哪，我会说——25次或30次。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
Yeah.
是的。
In the time I knew her, Grandma Frieda's face was made of these pale white rectangular sheets of grafted flesh sewn together around an easy to imagine skull. Her nose was a misshapen bulb that was somewhere between human nose and pig nose. But of course, you know, the family that you're born into is the very definition of what seems normal.
在我认识她的日子里，祖母弗里达的脸是由那些苍白、长方形的植皮碎片拼凑而成的，缝合在一个容易想象的头骨上。她的鼻子是一个畸形的肉球，介于人的鼻子和猪鼻子之间。但当然，你出生的家庭本身就定义了什么是正常的。
And my sisters and cousins and I-- like, she made Jell-O for us, you know? She played Scrabble. Like, we loved her. We didn't think anything of it.
我和我的姐妹们、表亲们——她给我们做果冻，我们一起玩拼字游戏。我们爱她，我们对此不以为意。
In the late '50s, finally, after her father died and the corner store went broke at last, Frieda did get to teach again full time. It was a quarter century after she graduated from Goucher. She taught high school French. Apparently the first day of class she would always tell the students to take a good long stare at her face right now, just get it out of their systems.
20世纪50年代末，在她父亲去世且小杂货店终于破产后，弗里达终于得以重新全职教书。那距离她从高彻学院毕业已经过了四分之一个世纪。她教的是高中法语。显然，开学第一天她总是会告诉学生，现在可以好好盯着她的脸看个够，把那种好奇心彻底消除掉。
Grandma Frieda's years at Goucher college, she would bring them up a lot. She wore her Phi Beta Kappa honor society key from Goucher, and then she would explain to strangers what it was. At holiday dinners, if one of us brought somebody new around, she would work Goucher into the conversation. But also, I swear, I remember her bringing it up with cashiers at the grocery store on Green Spring Avenue, and with nurses in the hospital, which I know makes her sound like a crank or something, though really she was not.
祖母弗里达经常提起她在高彻学院的时光。她戴着那枚来自高彻的Phi Beta Kappa荣誉协会钥匙，然后会向陌生人解释那是什么。在节日晚餐上，如果我们带了新朋友来，她会把高彻学院强行加入谈话中。但我也发誓，我记得她甚至在格林斯普林大道的杂货店里跟收银员提过，还有在医院里跟护士也提过，我知道这让她听起来像是个怪人，但实际上她真不是。
Well, she talked about it because that was the only positive thing--
嗯，她谈论这些是因为那是她唯一积极的事——
That's all she had to talk about.
那是她唯一能聊的话题。
That's-- thank you, Barry. That's what I was trying to say.
那是——谢谢你，巴里。那正是我想要表达的。
Do you think that was one of the happiest times, or maybe the happiest time, of her life, when she was at Goucher?
你觉得她在高彻学院的那段时光，是她一生中最快乐的，或者说可能是最快乐的时光吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我是这么认为的。
Oh, I would say probably.
噢，我大概会同意。
There's a page in her Goucher file that I guess was filled out when she first entered the school, typed on an old manual typewriter. It lists her name, her childhood address, her age-- which is 17. 17. I've stared at that number for a long while. Like, OK, when this was written down, that number was accurate.
她的高彻档案里有一页，我想是她刚入学时填写的，是用老式手动打字机打出来的。上面列着她的名字、童年住址、她的年龄——17岁。17岁。我盯着那个数字看了很久。就是，好吧，当这行字写下来的时候，那个数字是准确的。
She was 17. And honestly, like, I'd never pictured her at 17 before this. A kid with pretty skin-- the acne treatment apparently worked like a charm-- looking forward to so many things. I knew her in her last 20 years. But her first 20, I don't know, it was comforting to think that she got those too.
她当时17岁。老实说，在看到这些之前，我从没想象过她17岁的样子。一个皮肤白皙的孩子——痤疮治疗显然非常成功——对未来充满期待。我只认识她生命中最后的20年。但她最初的20年，我不知道，想到她也曾拥有过那段时光，让人感到一丝安慰。
That that was just as real a part of her life as the part that I knew. I think it's easy to decide that what's happening like, right now, right this second, is the most important thing. But in fact, the moments before are just as real as the moments right now. And it all looks so much more complicated if you take them into account.
那段时光也是她生命中真实的一部分，就像我所认识的那一部分一样。我觉得人们很容易认定当下，也就是此时此刻发生的事情是最重要的。但实际上，过去的时刻与现在的时刻一样真实。如果把这些都考虑进去，一切看起来就会复杂得多。
Well, today on our show we have stories like the moment that's documented in my Grandma Frieda's college file, the moment before things went to hell. We have two very different stories. In one, politicians nearly solved something that today is so deeply unsolved that we have shut down our government over it. In the other, post divorce time travels for 90 minutes into pre-divorce. WBEZ Chicago, I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在今天的节目里，我们有一些像我祖母弗里达大学档案中记录的那种时刻的故事，即事情陷入绝境之前的时刻。我们有两个非常不同的故事。在第一个故事里，政客们几乎解决了一个在今天看来由于太过棘手，导致我们不得不因此关闭政府的问题。在另一个故事里，离婚后的时光穿越到了离婚前90分钟。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Where Have You Gone, Barbara Jordan? Our Nation Turns Its Lonely Eyes to You. OK, so government gets shut down over a border wall. President says there's a national emergency. Democrats say there isn't one.
第一幕，芭芭拉·乔丹，你去哪儿了？我们的国家正用孤独的目光注视着你。好吧，政府因为边境墙问题停摆了。总统说这是国家紧急状态，民主党人说根本不是。
But there is a moment before all this, before this whole conversation went into the divisive, nobody is listening to anybody hell that it seems to be in today. There was a moment back in the '90s when Congress had a bunch of people with completely opposing points of view on this sit down, hash it out, and come up with a solution to the whole thing. And they came up with one, a comprehensive one that would have fixed so many of the things that we're arguing about today. We wouldn't even be talking about this today this way. All of this would've played out differently.
但在这一切发生之前，在整个对话进入今天这种分裂、没人听得进任何人说话的炼狱之前，确实有过一个时刻。那是在90年代，国会有一群对这个问题持有完全相反观点的人坐下来，共同商讨，并想出了一个针对整个问题的解决方案。他们确实达成了一个全面的方案，本可以解决今天我们争论的许多问题。我们今天甚至不会以这种方式讨论这个问题。这一切本会以不同的方式演变。
And at the center of the whole thing was this one woman-- charismatic, principled, beloved by Democrats and Republicans, and so different from anybody we can think of in politics today. Her whole mission and philosophy of politics was so different from anything you see today. One of our producers, Miki Meek, like me and a few others here on our staff has become kind of obsessed with immigration these last few years. She has the story. And we start with a little context.
而这一切的中心是这样一位女性——魅力四射、原则性强、深受民主党和共和党人爱戴，与我们今天政坛中的任何人都截然不同。她的政治使命和哲学与你今天看到的任何东西都大相径庭。我们的制作人之一米基·米克，像我和我们组里的其他人一样，这几年对移民问题变得有些着迷。她带来了这个故事。我们先从一点背景开始。
In the 90s when all this happens, immigration hadn't become this nationally charged partisan issue. It was a topic that made most people's eyes glaze over. Most of the country didn't even know that a historic migration from Mexico to the US was underway. That is, unless you live in a state like Florida, Texas, or California where most of the undocumented immigrants were settling. In those states, voters were getting angry.
在90年代这一切发生时，移民问题还没有成为全国性的党派议题。那是一个让大多数人听了就想打瞌睡的话题。全国大部分地区甚至都不知道一场从墨西哥到美国的历史性移民潮正在进行中。除非你住在像佛罗里达、德克萨斯或加利福尼亚这样非法移民主要定居的州。在这些州，选民们开始愤怒了。
So the politics of immigration started to change. And the big bang that really launched everyone into this new world happened in California in 1994-- a ballot measure called Prop 187.
于是，移民政治开始改变。真正将所有人推入这个新世界的“大爆炸”发生在1994年的加利福尼亚州——一项名为第187号提案的公投措施。
Prop 187 banned undocumented immigrants and their kids from getting public benefits or going to schools, and made teachers and doctors turn over the names of anyone they knew or even suspected was undocumented. Huge parts of it were unconstitutional. The Californians voted for it by an overwhelming margin. For Democrats in the state, this was a wake up call.
187号提案禁止非法移民及其子女享受公共福利或上学，并要求教师和医生举报他们认识或甚至怀疑是非法移民的人。其大部分内容违宪。加州选民以压倒性多数投票支持它。对于该州的民主党人来说，这是一个警钟。
And one of the things that's so interesting when you listen back to all this stuff now is that they do not sound like the Democrats today. For instance, here's Senator Diane Feinstein from California. She was against the harsh restrictions of Prop 187, but at the same time she wanted to crack down on illegal immigration and she called for it on the Senate floor.
当你现在回听这些内容时，最有趣的一点是，他们听起来不像今天的民主党人。例如，这是来自加州的黛安·范斯坦参议员。她反对187号提案的严苛限制，但同时她也想打击非法移民，并在参议院会议厅呼吁采取行动。
There is simply no time to lose. Too many people are still able to illegally cross our borders and too few states, most notably California, carry the burden of having to support, educate, and often incarcerate, the hundreds of thousands who enter this country illegally each year.
根本没有时间浪费了。太多人仍然能够非法越过我们的边境，而太少的州，特别是加利福尼亚，承受着不得不支持、教育并经常监禁每年非法进入本国的数十万人的负担。
This is her in the mid '90s, and this next thing she says is eerily prophetic.
这是她在90年代中期发表的言论，接下来她说的话具有离奇的预言性。
Ladies and gentlemen, let me say to you what I, honest to God, believe is the truth. If we cannot affect sound, just, and moderate controls, the people of America will rise to stop all immigration. I am as sure as that as I am that I'm standing here now.
各位，让我告诉你们我向上帝发誓所相信的真相。如果我们不能采取合理、公正和温和的控制措施，美国人民将会奋起阻止所有移民。我对此确信无疑，就像我确信现在正站在这里一样。
You can almost picture her putting her hands up at the border of California, trying to prevent xenophobia from spreading. These were very different times and both sides moved quickly to figure out a solution. So Congress put together a team, a blue ribbon commission, to come up with proposals that Congress could turn into laws. I know how boring this sounds. Commissions are the joke of government, the place politicians send issues to die-- bureaucratic, ineffective.
你几乎可以想象她站在加利福尼亚边界举起双手，试图阻止仇外心理蔓延。那是截然不同的时代，双方都迅速采取行动寻找解决方案。因此，国会组建了一个蓝带委员会，来提出国会可以转化为法律的建议。我知道这听起来很无聊。委员会是政府的笑话，是政客们把问题扔进去让它烂掉的地方——官僚、低效。
But I promise, the story I'm going to tell you is not that. For starters, they packed this commission with people who are so different from each other that it's almost comical. On one side there was the guy who co-wrote Prop 187 and on the other side, a Democrat who helped almost three million undocumented immigrants get amnesty here. I spoke with all the commission members who are still alive. There's five of them.
但我保证，我要讲的故事可不是那样。首先，他们在这个委员会里塞进了彼此差异极大的人，简直到了滑稽的地步。一边是187号提案的合著者，另一边是一位帮助近三百万非法移民获得大赦的民主党人。我采访了所有在世的委员会成员。共有五位。
I told my wife that this commission will not be able to agree on whether it's Monday or Tuesday.
我告诉我的妻子，这个委员会连今天是周一还是周二都无法达成一致。
This is Michael Teitelbaum, a demographer that Republicans appointed.
这是迈克尔·泰特尔鲍姆，共和党任命的人口统计学家。
I didn't know all of the appointees but I knew some of them. And my conclusion was that there was such a wide range of opinion on this very contentious set of issues that there would be no way this commission could reach a consensus on anything.
我不认识所有的任命人员，但我认识其中一些。我的结论是，在这个非常具争议性的议题上，意见分歧之大，以至于委员会不可能在任何事情上达成共识。
That's where this remarkable woman came in, the hero of our story. Her name was Barbara Jordan, and she was a civil rights icon, a democratic representative from Texas who also incidentally was black and gay. She's been dead for more than 20 years now. And to understand the unique spot she held in American politics, some background.
这就是我们故事的英雄，那位非凡女性出场的地方。她的名字叫芭芭拉·乔丹，她是民权偶像，来自德克萨斯州的民主党代表，顺便提一下，她还是黑人和同性恋。她已经去世20多年了。为了了解她在当时的美国政坛占据的独特地位，我们先介绍一点背景。
She grew up in Houston, went to segregated schools and then law school. Started running for office in her 20s and broke a bunch of barriers. In the '60s she became the first black woman elected to the Texas legislature. And then in 1972, the first to serve in the US Congress from the south. She became this breakout national star during the Watergate hearings in 1974.
她在休斯顿长大，读的是种族隔离学校，后来又上了法学院。20多岁就开始参选，打破了许多障碍。60年代，她成为第一位当选德克萨斯州议员的黑人女性。1972年，成为第一位来自南方的美国国会议员。在1974年的水门事件听证会上，她成为了全国性的明星。
At the time, she was just a 30 something newcomer on the House Judiciary Committee that was deciding whether or not they were really going to impeach the President of the United States. And it's pretty much what you'd expect, a bunch of older white men on live TV sounding like your typical politician, giving their opening statements.
当时，她只是众议院司法委员会的一名30多岁的新人，该委员会正在决定是否真的要弹劾美国总统。这跟你预想的差不多，一群老白男在直播电视上听起来就像典型的政客，发表着开场陈述。
Until it came time for Jordan, who wore this big boxy orange suit, bright camera lights glaring off her black rimmed glasses-- a freshman Congresswoman, and at that point one of four black woman ever to serve in Congress. And when she opened her mouth, she spoke in this style that was grand, but also personal.
直到轮到乔丹发言，她穿着那套巨大的、方方正正的橙色西装，明亮的摄像灯在她的黑框眼镜上闪烁——一位国会一年级议员，当时仅有的四位担任国会议员的黑人女性之一。当她开口时，她的风格既宏大，又充满个人色彩。
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Mr. Chairman, you are a strong man. And it has not been easy, but we have tried as best we can to give you as much assistance as possible. Earlier today, we heard the beginning of the preamble to the Constitution of the United States-- we the people. It's a very eloquent beginning. But when that document was completed on the 17th of September in 1787, I was not included in that we the people. I felt somehow for many years that George Washington and Alexander Hamilton just left me out by mistake.
谢谢主席先生。主席先生，您是一位坚强的人。这并不容易，但我们已经尽力为您提供了尽可能多的协助。今天早些时候，我们听到了美国宪法序言的开头——“我们人民”。这是一个非常雄辩的开头。但是，当那份文件在1787年9月17日完成时，我并没有被包括在那个“我们人民”中。多年来，我总觉得乔治·华盛顿和亚历山大·汉密尔顿只是因为失误才把我排除在外。
When I first heard this, I put it on repeat. I love how she sounds. Even then, her voice was considered unusual, like JFK or Churchill, with maybe a little Katherine Hepburn thrown in there, which turns out is just how she spoke, whether she was on a stage or not. And at that moment during Watergate, millions of Americans heard her for the very first time and lots of them were like, wow, who is this woman talking this way?
第一次听到这段话时，我把它设为了循环播放。我喜欢她的声音。即使在当时，她的声音也被认为是与众不同的，就像肯尼迪或丘吉尔，可能还带点凯瑟琳·赫本的影子，事实证明这正是她说话的方式，无论她是否在舞台上。在那一刻的水门事件中，数百万美国人第一次听到了她的声音，许多人都惊呼，哇，这个说话方式如此独特的人是谁？
--but through the process of amendment, interpretation, and court decision, I have finally been included in we the people. Today, I am an inquisitor. And hyperbole would not be fictional and would not overstate the solemness that I feel right now. My faith in the Constitution is whole, it is complete, it is total. And I am not going to sit here and be an idle spectator to the diminution, the subversion, the destruction, of the Constitution. A president is impeachable if he attempts to subvert the Constitution.
——但通过修正、解释和法院判决的过程，我终于被包含在“我们人民”之中了。今天，我是一名调查者。修辞手法并非虚构，也绝不会夸大我此刻感到的庄严。我对宪法的信仰是完整的、彻底的、全面的。我绝不会坐在这里，做一个对宪法的削弱、颠覆、破坏无动于衷的旁观者。如果总统试图颠覆宪法，那么他就是可弹劾的。
She explained, the president is not above the law. He is not above the Constitution. It was a galvanizing moment. People remarked how fair minded and serious she was. Dan Rather, who covered the Watergate hearings, said later that when Jordan finished there was no doubt in his mind that the president would be impeached or have to resign. He said she created this feeling of, as hard as it seems we have to go on with this. We don't have a choice.
她解释道，总统不高于法律。他不高于宪法。这是一个鼓舞人心的时刻。人们评论她有多么公平公正、多么严肃。报道水门事件听证会的丹·拉瑟后来表示，当乔丹结束发言时，他心里毫无疑问总统会被弹劾或被迫辞职。他说，她创造了一种感觉，那就是无论看起来多么艰难，我们都必须继续下去。我们别无选择。
Jordan's office was immediately swarming with camera crews and flooded with fan mail from all over the country. Her appeal cut across party lines. One man even put up 25 billboards that said, "Thank you Barbara Jordan for explaining our Constitution." She had suddenly been catapulted into this spot where people looked at her as a moral authority at a particularly cynical moment in politics.
乔丹的办公室立刻挤满了摄制组，收到了来自全国各地的粉丝来信。她的吸引力跨越了党派界限。一个人甚至竖起了25块广告牌，上面写着：“感谢芭芭拉·乔丹为我们解释宪法。”她在政坛 cynicism（愤世嫉俗）盛行的特殊时刻，突然被推到了一个人们视她为道德权威的位置。
In Congress her colleagues like to joke that Jordan had the voice of God, which is kind of true. Her mom and dad were Baptist. Dad did some preaching. Her mom gave a lot of speeches, too. That's just how she grew up talking.
在国会，她的同事们喜欢开玩笑说乔丹有着“上帝的声音”，这倒也有些道理。她的父母都是浸信会信徒。父亲偶尔布道。母亲也经常发表演讲。她就是在这样的环境里成长起来的。
Jordan was a champion debater in college. She says that's where she picked up the style of speech. Two years after Watergate, Barbara got asked to give the big speech at the Democratic National Convention-- the keynote. The other keynote speaker that year was John Glenn, senator and astronaut. The crowd barely paid attention to him. Then Barbara Jordan took the stage.
乔丹在大学里是辩论冠军。她说她就是在那儿学会了这种演讲风格。水门事件发生两年后，芭芭拉受邀在民主党全国代表大会上发表主旨演讲。那年的另一位主旨发言人是参议员兼宇航员约翰·格伦。人群几乎没注意他。然后芭芭拉·乔丹登上了舞台。
This is by far the biggest ovation anyone has received here in this opening session of the Democratic Convention. This time the convention has really come alive.
这是民主党大会开幕式上任何人获得过的最大欢呼声。这次大会真的被点燃了。
This video is totally electrifying to watch. The clapping went on for three minutes straight before Jordan could speak.
看这段录像简直让人热血沸腾。掌声持续了整整三分钟，乔丹才得以开口讲话。
Thank you. Thank you. There is something different about tonight. There is something special about tonight. What is different, what is special? I, Barbara Jordan, am a keynote speaker.
谢谢。谢谢。今晚有什么不同。今晚有什么特别。有什么不同，有什么特别的？我，芭芭拉·乔丹，是一名主旨发言人。
She was the first African-American to give the convention's keynote. Afterward, there was a movement to make her Jimmy Carter's Vice President, though she quickly swatted that down. She issued a press release saying, he'd never pick someone who's both black and a woman.
她是第一位在该大会上发表主旨演讲的非裔美国人。此后，有人提议让她成为吉米·卡特的副总统竞选搭档，尽管她很快就拒绝了。她发表了一份新闻稿称，他永远不会选择一个既是黑人又是女性的人。
Cut to 1992, 16 years later. Jordan's retired, leading a quiet life in Austin with her partner and teaching at a university, but the government needs someone to head its bipartisan immigration team. Susan Martin, a veteran of immigration policy fights on Capitol Hill, leads the search. Jordan had never worked on the issue, but she was Martin's first pick.
转眼到1992年，16年后。乔丹已经退休，在奥斯汀与伴侣过着安静的生活，并在大学教书，但政府需要一个人来领导其两党移民工作组。国会山上移民政策斗争的资深人士苏珊·马丁负责搜寻人选。乔丹此前从未涉足该问题，但她是马丁的首选。
I had never met her but I thought that she stood for integrity, and balance, and fairness. And she started off saying she was just too busy. She thought it was an important issue, it wasn't that at all, but she couldn't do it.
我从没见过她，但我认为她代表了正直、平衡和公平。她一开始说她太忙了。她认为这是一个重要议题，情况并非不重要，但她分身乏术。
At that time, Jordan had multiple sclerosis, sometimes needed a wheelchair and walker to get around. But Susan said she kept trying to convince her, telling her anti-immigrant views were spreading. The rhetoric was getting more racist, and starting to divide the country. Jordan was alarmed by all that. She didn't want immigrants to become scapegoats. So she said yes.
当时，乔丹患有多发性硬化症，有时需要轮椅和助行器才能走动。但苏珊说她一直试图说服她，告诉她反移民的观点正在蔓延。言论变得越来越种族主义，并开始分裂国家。乔丹对此感到震惊。她不想让移民成为替罪羊。于是她答应了。
As someone who's been watching this immigration debate play out for the past few years it was incredible to hear what Barbara Jordan pulled off, how she managed to get people who didn't think they could agree to agree. She brought them to unanimous consensus on nearly everything. She forced them to stake out a middle ground on stuff that was controversial then and still is today.
作为一个观察过去几年移民辩论的人，听到芭芭拉·乔丹所取得的成就，以及她如何设法让那些原本认为无法达成一致的人达成一致，简直令人难以置信。她几乎在所有事情上都促成了全体一致的共识。她强迫他们在当时具争议性且至今依然具争议性的问题上立足于中间地带。
I asked all the commissioners how exactly she got this thing to work. They told me that Jordan first set up a bunch of ground rules for how they could make decisions together, all nine of them. Again, here's Michael Teitelbaum, one of the Republican appointees to the commission.
我问了所有委员，她究竟是如何让这件事奏效的。他们告诉我，乔丹首先为他们九个人如何共同做出决定制定了一套基本规则。再次提到，这是共和党任命的委员之一，迈克尔·泰特尔鲍姆。
I remember her saying, we are nine in number but we are not the Supreme Court. If we vote 5 to 4, on something that is a meaningless set of recommendations. So I don't think we should be seeking small majorities for opinion A or B, but we should be seeking instead broad consensus. And everybody agreed on that.
我记得她说，我们有九个人，但我们不是最高法院。如果我们在某件事上以5比4投票，那不过是一堆毫无意义的建议。所以我认为我们不应该为了观点A或B寻找微弱的多数票，而应该寻找广泛的共识。每个人都同意了。
For Barbara, this approach was bigger than just the commission. She didn't see compromise as a sign of weakness. She saw it as a moral imperative. She taught this in her college ethics and political values classes. She believed it was actually immoral to not compromise if your job was to legislate.
对芭芭拉来说，这种方法不仅仅是为了委员会。她不认为妥协是软弱的表现。她认为妥协是一种道德义务。她在大学的伦理和政治价值观课程中教授这一点。她认为如果你的工作是立法，那么不妥协实际上是不道德的。
When she was still a politician, she had a reputation as a pragmatist who despised ideologues and party purists. She liked drinking and playing guitar with conservatives after hours and she had no problems cutting deals or making friends with her polar opposites. In fact, in the Texas Senate, she thought it was the only way she could get any change to happen.
当她还是个政客时，她被誉为一个蔑视狂热分子和党派纯粹主义者的务实主义者。她喜欢在下班后和保守派一起喝酒弹吉他，而且她处理达成交易或与截然相反的人交朋友毫无压力。事实上，在德克萨斯州参议院，她认为这是她能够实现任何变革的唯一途径。
She'd take opportunities where she could find them, which is how she later got West Virginian Senator Robert Byrd, a former Ku Klux Klan member, to help her get enough votes to expand the Voting Rights Act to Mexican Americans.
她会抓住任何机会，这也是她后来如何让西弗吉尼亚州参议员罗伯特·伯德（一位前三K党成员）帮她获得足够票数，以扩大《投票权法案》覆盖墨西哥裔美国人的原因。
On the commission, Jordan also worked with everyone to come up with language that would establish tone which was just as important as the actual policies themselves. The tone would be respectful, send a message that they were listening to both sides. So on one hand, she was tough on illegal immigration.
在委员会，乔丹还与大家合作，制定了语调，这与实际政策本身同样重要。语调将是尊重的，传递出他们愿意倾听双方意见的信息。所以一方面，她对非法移民态度强硬。
We've got to have the strength to say no to the people who are not supposed to get in. We need to make deportation a part of a credible immigration policy.
我们必须有力量对那些不应该进入的人说不。我们需要让驱逐出境成为可信移民政策的一部分。
But at the same time, she was pro immigration.
但同时，她也是支持移民的。
The commission believes that legal immigration has strengthened the country and it continue to do so. We strongly denounce-- denounce on our commission-- the hostility which seems to be developing around immigrants. That is not healthy when we seek to blame immigrants for all of our social ills. We cannot sustain ourselves as a nation if we condone divisiveness in this society of immigrants.
委员会认为合法移民加强了国家，并将继续这样做。我们强烈谴责——谴责，我们的委员会——围绕移民产生的敌意。当我们试图将所有社会弊病归咎于移民时，这是不健康的。如果我们默许这个移民社会中的分裂，我们就无法作为一个国家维持下去。
To me, one of the most impressive things I learned about this bipartisan commission is just how all out they went for five years. Early on they were constantly on the road because they wanted input from the rest of the country. In El Paso, Chicago, Seattle, San Diego, Nogales, and a bunch of other places. They held public hearings that were basically open mic sessions, that lasted for hours. They also did ride alongs with border patrol, toured refugee camps in Kenya, and met with government officials in Mexico.
对我来说，我从这个两党委员会中学到的最令人印象深刻的事情之一，就是他们在五年里付出的努力程度。起初，他们一直在路上，因为他们想要得到全国其他地方的反馈。在埃尔帕索、芝加哥、西雅图、圣地亚哥、诺加莱斯和其他许多地方。他们举行了基本上是开放麦式的公共听证会，持续了几个小时。他们还随边境巡逻队巡逻，参观了肯尼亚的难民营，并与墨西哥政府官员会面。
While they were there, one of the commissioners told me this poignant detail. When they got to buildings that didn't have ramps, they just picked Jordan up in her wheelchair and carried her in. When you compare today to back then, the single biggest difference is that it was possible for the two sides to just sit down and talk about how to cut down on illegal immigration, mainly because politicians were still all over the map on the issue. Positions hadn't hardened along predictable party lines.
当他们在那里时，一位委员告诉了我这个感人的细节。当他们到达没有坡道的建筑物时，他们直接把坐在轮椅上的乔丹抬了进去。当你比较现在和那时时，最大的区别在于，双方当时有可能坐下来讨论如何减少非法移民，主要是因为政客们在这个问题上仍然分歧很大。立场尚未按照可预测的党派路线硬化。
Yes, Republicans were generally more skeptical about immigration, and Democrats were more in favor of it. But there were also lots of pro-business Republicans who wanted cheap labor, and pro-union Democrats who did not. They wanted to protect American workers. So this was a moment when things were more malleable, before immigration became such a loaded symbolic issue. It was a moment before so many families moved here.
是的，共和党人通常对移民持怀疑态度，而民主党人则更支持。但也有许多亲商业的共和党人想要廉价劳动力，而亲工会的民主党人则不想要。他们想保护美国工人。所以这是一个情况更具灵活性、在移民问题变得如此沉重的象征性议题之前的时刻。这是一个在如此多家庭搬到这里之前的时刻。
Most of the undocumented were young single men coming for jobs. And it was a moment when, unlike today, both sides, Democrats and Republicans, agreed that illegal immigration was an urgent problem. Here's Bill Clinton giving his State of the Union in 1995. At that point, the undocumented population had grown to around five million, less than half of what it is now.
大多数非法移民是为工作而来的年轻单身男性。那是一个与今天不同、双方（民主党和共和党）都同意非法移民是一个紧迫问题的时刻。这是比尔·克林顿在1995年发表的国情咨文。那时，非法人口已增长到约500万，不到现在的一半。
All Americans, not only in the states most heavily affected but in every place in this country, are rightly disturbed by the large numbers of illegal aliens entering our country. The jobs they hold might otherwise be held by citizens or legal immigrants.
所有美国人，不仅是在受影响最严重的州，而且在这个国家的每个地方，都对大量非法进入我国的外国人感到正当的困扰。他们从事的工作本来可以由公民或合法移民来担任。
In case this isn't clear, at the time protecting the working class from an influx of cheap labor was still a central part of the Democratic Party's platform. And the way to protect American workers and stop people from entering the country seemed obvious to the commission-- make it impossible for undocumented workers to get jobs. This was the easiest point of agreement for the commission. They voted to hit businesses with big fines and even jail time if they were caught hiring undocumented workers, and to create a mandatory electronic system that employers would use to check if job applicants were legal to work. This eventually became known as E-Verify.
如果还不清楚的话，当时保护工人阶级免受廉价劳动力涌入的影响仍然是民主党纲领的核心部分。而保护美国工人并阻止人们非法入境的方法对委员会来说似乎显而易见——让非法移民无法获得工作。这是委员会最容易达成共识的一点。他们投票决定，如果企业被发现雇佣非法移民，将处以巨额罚款甚至监禁，并建立一个强制性的电子系统，雇主将用它来核实求职者是否有合法工作资格。这后来被称为“电子验证”（E-Verify）。
A thornier issue was birthright citizenship, the thing that President Trump said he wanted to end just before the midterms. This is the law that says if you enter the country illegally and have a child here, that child is a citizen. Jordan settled this really quickly. She flexed her moral authority because birthright citizenship is in the Constitution. Here's one of the commissioners, Bruce Morrison.
另一个更棘手的问题是出生公民权，也就是特朗普总统在期中选举前说他想终止的问题。这是法律规定，如果你非法入境并在那里生下一个孩子，那个孩子就是公民。乔丹很快就解决了这个问题。她运用了她的道德权威，因为出生公民权载于宪法中。这是其中一位委员，布鲁斯·莫里森。
There were members, I won't name a particular members, but there were members who had the anchor baby line. And Barbara made clear where she stood on the 14th Amendment, and that was one of the few examples where she just put her foot down and basically said, you know, over my dead body.
有些成员，我不会指名道姓，但确实有成员提出了“锚定婴儿”的言论。芭芭拉明确了她在第14修正案上的立场，这是她坚持原则、基本上说“除非我死了”的极少数例子之一。
The 14th Amendment reads all persons born or naturalized in the United States are citizens.
第14修正案写道，所有在美国出生或入籍的人都是公民。
The 14th Amendment overturned the Dred Scott decision which said black people born in America could never be citizens.
第14修正案推翻了“斯科特案”的判决，该判决称在美国出生的黑人永远不能成为公民。
I am not about to advocate changing the 14th Amendment to the Constitution of the United States. Those parents are not citizens but that child is a citizen. And as a citizen of this country, that child is entitled to benefits and they are not to be taken away.
我绝不会主张修改美国宪法的第14修正案。那些父母不是公民，但那个孩子是公民。作为这个国家的公民，那个孩子有权享有福利，不应被剥夺。
The most explosive issue the commission faced, the most difficult question Jordan guided them through, had to do with immigrant families arriving in the US. Specifically, should people be allowed to bring their whole extended families over-- parents and brothers and sisters, and once they get green cards their spouses and kids? President Trump calls this chain migration. He thinks it's unfair and dangerous, foreigners taking advantage of the system.
委员会面临的最具爆发力的问题，也是乔丹引导他们解决的最困难的问题，与抵达美国的移民家庭有关。具体来说，是否应该允许人们带上他们的整个大家庭——父母和兄弟姐妹，一旦他们获得绿卡，是否可以带上配偶和孩子？特朗普总统称之为“连锁移民”。他认为这是不公平和危险的，外国人占了系统的便宜。
But Jordan's commission came up with a totally different way to frame this issue. She talked about it in a way that's much more humane than how we hear it talked about today, with no fear mongering. Though it took them a year to figure this out the commission said, let's just be practical about the situation. They said, look at how things are going now with family visas. It's a total backed up mess.
但乔丹的委员会想出了一种完全不同的方式来构建这个问题。她谈论它的方式比我们今天听到的更人道，没有散布恐惧。尽管委员会花了一年时间才弄清楚这一点，但他们说，让我们务实地看待这种情况。他们说，看看现在家庭签证的情况。这完全是一团糟。
At the time, if you were a US citizen with a sibling in the Philippines, the wait time to get into the US was 18 years. The commissioners felt the US was making promises it couldn't keep. Again, here's former commissioner Bruce Morrison.
当时，如果你是一个在美国有菲律宾籍兄弟姐妹的美国公民，进入美国的等待时间是18年。委员们认为美国在做它无法兑现的承诺。同样，这是前委员布鲁斯·莫里森。
This, to me, was the number one issue facing our immigration system, that we were dividing families, that we were making people choose whether they should break the rules by being here illegally to live with their spouse, or whether they should be exiled. And that's a choice no family should make.
对我来说，这是我们移民系统面临的第一大问题，即我们正在拆散家庭，我们正在迫使人们做出选择：是为了与配偶生活在一起而非法留在当地，还是为了遵守法律而流亡。那是任何家庭都不应该做的选择。
They said, let's prioritize. Most people can agree that the most important thing is for parents to be together with their kids as quickly as possible. So they said, let's only give visas to parents and minor children, and not admit anyone else. This would knock lots of people off the waiting list.
他们说，让我们确定优先次序。大多数人可以同意，最重要的事情是父母能够尽快与孩子在一起。所以他们说，只给父母和未成年子女提供签证，不接纳任何人。这将把许多人从等待名单上划掉。
Say for instance, you are an adult citizen and your brother and two sisters had been waiting for a decade. Suddenly, sorry, there's no space for them. Also, if your kids were adults, they'd be out of luck, too. So it was a tough policy, but it was generous, too. Doing this would cut the long backlogs, free up more visas. And they agreed to temporarily give out even more to bring in all the kids and spouses on the waiting list as quickly as possible.
比如，你是一名成年公民，你的兄弟和两个姐妹已经等了十年了。突然间，抱歉，没有他们的名额了。此外，如果你的孩子已经是成年人，他们也没戏了。所以这是一项严厉的政策，但也很慷慨。这样做将减少积压，腾出更多签证。他们同意暂时发放更多签证，以便尽快把等待名单上的所有孩子和配偶接过来。
Then once that list was cleared, they'd make sure new applicants got reunited with their families in the US within a year. They also built in special exceptions to allow in adult kids with disabilities and kids who put in applications as children but aged out because of long wait times. Of course, there was no getting around the fact that this approach would leave more than a million siblings and others out in the cold, unable to move to the US. And not surprisingly, this upset a lot of people, including Republicans.
然后，一旦名单清理完毕，他们将确保新的申请人能在一年内与他们在美的家人团聚。他们还设立了特别例外条款，允许残疾成年子女和作为孩子申请但因漫长等待时间而超龄的子女进入。当然，这一做法无法回避一个事实：这会让一百多万兄弟姐妹和其他人被拒之门外，无法搬到美国。不出所料，这让很多人感到不满，包括共和党人。
Representative Dick Armey told The New York Times that the commission's proposal was a quote, "misguided attempt to make legal immigrants the scapegoats for America's problems." Protesters picketed the commission at public hearings. Here's a reporter pushing Barbara Jordan during a press conference in DC.
迪克·阿米议员告诉《纽约时报》，委员会的建议是“试图将合法移民作为美国问题替罪羊的误导性尝试”。抗议者在公开听证会上围攻委员会。这是记者在华盛顿特区的新闻发布会上追问芭芭拉·乔丹。
Many of the critics of these recommendations have qualified them as anti family and inhumane. How do you respond to that?
许多批评这些建议的人称其为反家庭和不人道的。您对此有何回应？
These recommendations are not anti family. Our recommendations make it easier for spouses and minor children to unite and not remain apart for such extended periods of time. And we had testimony from people, immigrants, who said I would love to have my wife with me, or my young son or daughter. And how do you say to, that person, but we've got to get somebody else's brother or sister? It was a matter of reinforcing a priority in the nuclear family.
这些建议并非反家庭。我们的建议使得配偶和未成年子女更容易团聚，而不必长期分离。我们收到了移民的证词，他们说我想让我的妻子，或者我的年幼儿子或女儿和我在一起。你怎么能对那个人说，但我们得先顾及别人的兄弟姐妹？这是一个加强核心家庭优先权的问题。
In 1995, President Clinton came out strong backing the commission saying their recommendations were consistent with his own views which were quote, "pro family, pro work, pro naturalization." The commission's report waded into the most controversial issues and made big, tough recommendations. They'd eliminate the diversity visa lottery and shrink the number of visas for low wage, unskilled workers. They called for harsh sanctions against businesses that hire undocumented workers.
1995年，克林顿总统强烈支持委员会，称他们的建议符合他自己的观点，即“亲家庭、亲工作、亲入籍”。委员会的报告深入研究了最具争议的问题，并提出了重大、严厉的建议。他们将取消多元化签证抽奖，减少发放给低薪、非技术工人的签证数量。他们呼吁对雇佣非法移民的企业实施严厉制裁。
They'd gradually moved from an immigration system that brings in mostly family members to one that brings in workers who have skills the US lacks. They said every few years, Congress should review how many people should be admitted into the country based on what the economy needs. And for the short term, they propose cutting overall legal immigration by a third. But at the same time, there was another side to their recommendations.
他们将逐渐从一个主要引入家庭成员的移民系统，转向一个引入美国缺乏技能的工人的系统。他们建议国会每几年根据经济需求评估应该接纳多少人。短期内，他们提议将整体合法移民减少三分之一。但同时，他们的建议也有另一面。
The commission wanted to keep refugees flowing into the country. They wanted protections and due process for people who get caught up in the immigration system and alternatives to detention for them. They insisted that legal immigrants were entitled to public benefits and welfare. They called for stricter enforcement of hate crime laws. They wanted to fund job training for American workers who were displaced by immigrants and to give money and advice to communities with new large immigrant populations, hoping this would make the whole transition less fraught and resentful.
委员会希望保持难民流入。他们希望为卷入移民系统的人提供保护和正当程序，并提供拘留替代方案。他们坚持认为合法移民有权享受公共福利。他们呼吁更严格地执行仇恨犯罪法。他们希望为被移民取代的美国工人提供职业培训资金，并向有大量新移民的社区提供金钱和建议，希望这能使整个过渡过程减少焦虑和怨恨。
By late 1995, it's clear that getting all this passed won't be easy but they have the president and the immigration subcommittees in the House and Senate on their side. And at that critical moment, Barbara Jordan got sick because of complications from leukemia which she'd had for a while but kept secret. She died within weeks. She was 59 years old. Again, here's Susan Martin, the woman who first hired Jordan for the commission.
到1995年底，很明显要通过这一切并不容易，但他们有总统以及众议院和参议院移民小组委员会的支持。就在那个关键时刻，芭芭拉·乔丹因白血病并发症病倒了，她患病已久但一直保密。她在几周内就去世了。她才59岁。再次提到，这是苏珊·马丁，那位最初聘请乔丹加入委员会的人。
I found out because I got a call from her partner. And all of the commissioners and all of the staff were just, you know, they can't believe it's happened. But it was also a very serious political loss because she had the stature and the voice to be able to make sure that the commission's recommendations were heard.
我发现是因为我接到了她伴侣的电话。所有的委员和工作人员都，你知道，简直不敢相信发生了什么。但这也是一个非常严重的政治损失，因为她有地位和声望来确保委员会的建议被听见。
That kind of authority, that's what was missing when Congress finally took up the commission's recommendations in 1996, without Jordan there to guide the debate. An astonishing variety of people came out and rallied against them. Immigrant rights groups teamed up with agribusiness and manufacturing to water down the sanctions against employers who hire undocumented workers. High tech firms opposed the cuts to worker visas. Religious groups didn't want any changes to family visas. And they won.
那种权威，正是1996年国会终于审议委员会建议时所缺少的，当时乔丹已经不在了，无法引导辩论。令人惊奇的是，各种各样的人出来联合反对这些建议。移民权利团体与农业综合企业和制造业联手，削弱了对雇佣非法移民的雇主的制裁。高科技公司反对削减工人签证。宗教团体不希望对家庭签证做任何改变。而他们赢了。
Because she wasn't there to push them. It's that simple. She wasn't there.
因为她不在那里推动他们。就这么简单。她不在那儿。
This is Senator Alan Simpson. He was the chair of the Senate immigration subcommittee and had a front row seat as the proposals fell apart.
这是艾伦·辛普森参议员。他是参议院移民小组委员会的主席，亲眼目睹了提案的瓦解。
And when she disappeared, then the interest groups came in and said, boy, she's gone now. We'll just get in and chop this baby to bits, which they did.
当她消失后，那些利益集团进来说，天哪，她现在不在了。我们这就进去把这个婴儿撕成碎片，他们确实也这么做了。
Soon enough, President Clinton backed away from his earlier endorsement of the commission and ended up signing some of the most punitive legislation against legal permanent residents. It restricted their access to food stamps and Medicaid and made it easier to deport them. Barbara Jordan's vision of a grand compromise was dead. The commissioners and Senator Simpson all told me, if she'd lived--
不久，克林顿总统收回了他早先对委员会的认可，最终签署了一些针对合法永久居民的最具惩罚性的立法。它限制了他们获取食品券和医疗补助的途径，并使驱逐他们变得更容易。芭芭拉·乔丹的伟大妥协愿景破灭了。委员们和辛普森参议员都告诉我，如果她还活着——
We'd have something better than whatever they got now, that's all I can tell you. I don't know what aspect it would be, whether it would be enforcement or border enforcement or legalization or whatever, whatever, whatever. But it would be a hell of a lot better than whatever you've got now.
我们现在的处境会比现在得到的要好，我只能告诉你这么多。我不知道会是哪方面，不管是执法、边境执法还是合法化什么的，但肯定会比你现在拥有的好得多。
Today when Barbara Jordan's name comes up in politics, it's mainly from Republicans. That's one of the things that got me interested in her in the first place. These immigration hardliners waving around the name of a liberal black woman, a civil rights icon, saying she's with us. Here's former Attorney General Jeff Sessions, one of her biggest fans.
今天，当芭芭拉·乔丹的名字在政治中出现时，主要是出自共和党人之口。这也是我最初对她感兴趣的原因之一。这些移民强硬派挥舞着一位自由派黑人女性、民权偶像的名字，说她站在我们这一边。这是前司法部长杰夫·塞申斯，她的最大粉丝之一。
The late civil rights pioneer Barbara Jordan found that quote, "immigration of unskilled immigrants comes at a cost to unskilled US workers." I don't think there's any doubt about that.
已故民权先驱芭芭拉·乔丹发现，引述，“非熟练移民的移民是以牺牲非熟练美国工人为代价的。”我认为对此毫无疑问。
Here's Laura Ingraham on Fox News with Bill O'Reilly.
这是福克斯新闻的劳拉·英格拉汉姆与比尔·奥莱利的节目。
Well, I think Barbara Jordan had it right back in 1995. She was a Democrat Congresswoman, African-American, head of the Commission on Immigration Reform. And she said, look, deportation is crucial, right? Because--
嗯，我认为芭芭拉·乔丹在1995年说得很对。她是民主党国会议员、非裔美国人、移民改革委员会负责人。她说，看，驱逐出境是至关重要的，对吧？因为——
Even President Trump released a statement dedicated to Barbara Jordan, crediting her with his whole America first approach to immigration. The group that's been responsible for making Jordan this darling of immigration hardliners is called Numbers USA. They've even put her on TV again. This ad ran during the last presidential campaign.
甚至特朗普总统也发表了一份致力于芭芭拉·乔丹的声明，将他整个“美国优先”的移民方针归功于她。负责让乔丹成为移民强硬派宠儿的组织叫“Numbers USA”。他们甚至再次把她搬上了电视。这则广告是在上次总统竞选期间播放的。
The commission finds no national interest in continuing to import lesser skilled and unskilled workers to compete in the most vulnerable parts of our labor force. Many American workers do not have adequate job prospects. We should make their task easier to find employment, not harder.
委员会发现，继续引入低技能和非熟练工人来竞争我们劳动力中最脆弱的部分，并不符合国家利益。许多美国工人没有足够的工作前景。我们应该让他们更容易找到工作，而不是更难。
Paid for by Numbers USA.
由Numbers USA支付。
I was shocked.
我感到震惊。
I asked all the former commissioners what Jordan would think of her name being used this way. Some weren't that offended by it, but one of the Democratic appointees, Bruce Morrison, remembers the first time he saw it.
我问了所有前委员，乔丹会怎么看她的名字被这样使用。有些人对此并不那么反感，但其中一位民主党任命的人，布鲁斯·莫里森，记得他第一次看到时的感受。
I mean, I was shocked because if she were alive, somehow you can imagine the volcano going off and burying these people under its eruption of outrage, because she always engaged in things in absolute open good faith. She didn't mis-characterize what people said. She didn't play these games of taking people's statements out of context, and sort of try to make her a symbol of something she did not represent and did not support. That's a kind of theft of a precious commodity.
我是说，我很震惊，因为如果她还活着，你可以想象那座火山爆发，用愤怒的喷发掩埋这些人，因为她总是绝对真诚地从事工作。她没有歪曲别人的话。她没有玩那种断章取义、试图让她成为她并不代表也不支持的事物的象征的游戏。那是一种对珍贵商品的偷窃。
I get why Republicans cite her so much. They're saying, these ideas we're advocating, they're not crazy. Reasonable people thought these were reasonable solutions. Though Bruce Morrison points out, when the commission proposed these things they were part of a bigger package which also included things these Republicans don't support. And beyond that, Barbara Jordan's whole political vision was proudly about compromise and finding common ground. It's jarring to see her being cited by partisans as part of a bitter political war.
我理解为什么共和党人如此频繁地引用她。他们是在说，我们倡导的这些观点并不疯狂。理性的人认为这些是合理的解决方案。尽管布鲁斯·莫里森指出，当委员会提出这些建议时，它们是一个更大方案的一部分，其中也包括这些共和党人不支持的内容。而且除此之外，芭芭拉·乔丹的整个政治愿景自豪地关乎妥协和寻找共同点。看到她被党派人士引用为苦涩政治战争的一部分，真是让人不适。
Meanwhile on immigration, the Democrats seem to have left the playing field. In the midterms, a common strategy for lots of candidates was to stick to the stuff that wasn't controversial like the Dreamers and then change the subject to health care.
与此同时，在移民问题上，民主党人似乎离开了战场。在期中选举中，许多候选人的共同策略是坚持那些没有争议的内容，比如“梦想生”，然后把话题转向医疗保健。
The truth is, I'd counted on Barbara preaching my funeral. She always did make things sound a lot better than they were.
事实是，我指望芭芭拉主持我的葬礼。她总是能把事情说得比实际情况好得多。
This is one of her good friends, former Texas Governor Ann Richards, speaking at her funeral in Houston. They used to go to Lady Longhorns basketball games together.
这是她的一位好朋友，前德克萨斯州州长安·理查兹在休斯顿的葬礼上的讲话。她们过去常一起去看长角牛队的篮球比赛。
And now if we're going to be honest we have to say that there were some people who managed to resist Barbara's persuasive manner. When I was a county commissioner, Barbara was building her house out in the country down at the end of a narrow little tree-shaded lane. And it was about--
现在，如果我们诚实的话，我们必须说有些人设法抵制了芭芭拉的说服方式。当我还是县委员时，芭芭拉在乡下的一条狭窄的小路尽头盖了她的房子。那是在——
Richards said it was about a mile long, and there was a woman who owned some property in the middle of it. And this woman, she put a gate across the lane and padlocked it.
理查兹说那条路大约有一英里长，有一位妇女在路中间拥有一些房产。这个女人，她在路上装了一道门，还锁上了。
And it may be hard to imagine Barbara really hopping mad but she was. And she called me up and she said, Ann! Ann! This old woman has put a gate across my lane and the lane is used by everyone. And I want that gate down.
你可能很难想象芭芭拉真的会气急败坏，但她确实生气了。她给我打电话说，安！安！那个老太婆在我路上装了一道门，那条路每个人都在用。我要把那道门拆掉。
And years later I was going out to the house for a party and I thought about that old woman. And so I said Barbara, whatever happened to that old woman? And Barbara suppressed a smile and got that voice of the Lord inflection in her speech, and she said, well, Ann, that old woman died and went to hell. And that's pretty much how it went with Barbara. If reasoning didn't work, and prodding didn't work, and the law didn't work, divine intervention was bound to just overcome whatever.
几年后，我要去她家参加一个聚会，我想起了那个老太婆。于是我说，芭芭拉，那个老太婆后来怎么样了？芭芭拉抑制住笑容，用那种上帝般语调的声调说道，嗯，安，那个老太婆死了，下地狱去了。芭芭拉的事情大抵就是这样。如果推理不行，催促也不行，法律也不行，神圣的干预肯定会克服一切。
To fix the situation we are in now with immigration feels like it might actually require divine intervention. Things are way more complicated now than they were in the '90s. For starters, the undocumented population has gotten a lot bigger. It's gone from 3 million to 11 million.
解决我们现在移民问题似乎确实需要神圣的干预。现在的情况比90年代复杂得多。首先，非法移民人数大大增加了。从300万增加到了1100万。
It's no longer mostly single young men crossing back and forth across the border. We now have families who've been living here for a full generation, who've raised children. And as Barbara Jordan always feared, immigrants now get blamed for all sorts of problems. We're now in a situation she never anticipated.
不再主要是单身年轻男子在边境来回穿梭。我们现在有在这里生活了整整一代、抚养了孩子的家庭。正如芭芭拉·乔丹一直担心的那样，移民现在被归咎于各种各样的问题。我们现在处于她从未预料到的境地。
The problem today is much worse than anything she'd ever imagined. And the two parties are so much further apart. They listen to each other so much less. It's hard to picture how even Barbara Jordan could get much done.
今天的问题比她想象的任何事情都要严重得多。而且两党之间的鸿沟要大得多。他们倾听对方的机会也少得多。很难想象连芭芭拉·乔丹能做多少事情。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show. Thanks to the other members of the Jordan commission we talked to, Bob Hill, Lindsey Lowell, Nelson Merced, Warren Leiden, and Paul Donnelly.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。感谢我们交谈过的乔丹委员会的其他成员，鲍勃·希尔、林赛·洛厄尔、尼尔森·梅赛德、沃伦·雷登和保罗·唐纳利。
Many fear the future, many are distrustful of their leaders, and believe that their voices are never heard.
许多人对未来感到恐惧，许多人对他们的领导人不信任，并认为他们的声音从未被听见。
This is Barbara Jordan speaking in a very divisive time just a couple of years after President Nixon's impeachment hearings and Vietnam at the Democratic National Convention.
这是芭芭拉·乔丹在尼克松总统弹劾听证会和越南战争几年后一个非常分裂的时代，在民主党全国代表大会上发表的讲话。
But a spirit of harmony will survive in America only if each of us remembers that we share a common destiny, if each of us remembers when self-interest and bitterness seem to prevail, that we share a common destiny. We are a generous people, so why can't we be generous with each other?
但只有我们每个人都记住我们共享共同的命运，只有我们每个人都记住当私利和痛苦似乎占上风时，我们共享共同的命运，和谐的精神才能在美国幸存下来。我们是一个慷慨的民族，那么为什么我们不能彼此慷慨呢？
But this is the great danger America faces, that we will cease to be one nation, and become instead a collection of interest groups-- city against suburb, region against region, individual against individual, each seeking to satisfy private wants. If that happens, who then will speak for America? Who then will speak for the common good?
但这正是美国面临的巨大危险，即我们将不再是一个国家，而是变成了一群利益集团的集合——城市对抗郊区，地区对抗地区，个人对抗个人，每个人都在寻求满足私人欲望。如果那样发生了，谁来为美国说话？谁来为共同利益说话？
Coming up, your ex-wife has a few thoughts about your marriage and she makes a movie about it. That does not sound like that's going to be a good experience for you. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，你的前妻对你们的婚姻有一些想法，她还拍了一部关于它的电影。听起来那对你来说不会是个好的体验。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，将在芝加哥公共广播电台播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, Before Things Went To Hell, stories of the moment before things went terribly wrong back when things could've turned out differently, but of course they didn't. We've arrived at Act Two of our program-- Act Two, Director's Cut.
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《事情陷入绝境之前》，讲述在事情变糟、原本可能发生转变却最终没有发生的时刻之前的故事。我们到了节目的第二幕——第二幕，导演剪辑版。
So the person in this next story finds himself in a situation that not many of us are ever going to be in. His ex-wife decided to revisit the part of their lives before their marriage went to hell and make a movie about it-- or anyway, about a couple whose life seems very, very parallel to theirs in lots of ways.
所以，下一个故事中的主角发现自己处于我们大多数人永远不会遇到的境地。他的前妻决定回顾他们婚姻陷入绝境之前的生活，并拍了一部电影——或者说，关于一对生活在许多方面与他们非常平行的夫妇。
This fictional couple gets married real young, they're trying to make it in LA, the woman gets a big break, she leaves the husband at that point. This all happened in real life, too. The guy's name is Will Weldon. Elna Baker explains what happened next.
这对虚构的夫妇年纪轻轻就结婚了，他们试图在洛杉矶出人头地，女方有了重大突破，随后在那一刻离开了丈夫。这一切在现实生活中也发生了。那个男人的名字叫威尔·威尔登。埃尔娜·贝克解释了接下来发生的事情。
Will heard about the movie from some friends when his ex-wife started working on it. The very thought of it made him anxious. His ex, Rebecca, eventually brought it up with him. She said the film was only loosely based on their marriage, which definitely did not help. He tried to put it out of his head. A year and a half later, he was scrolling around on-line.
威尔从一些朋友那里得知了电影的事，当时他的前妻开始创作它。一想到这个，他就感到焦虑。他的前妻丽贝卡最终和他提了这件事。她说电影只是松散地基于他们的婚姻，这绝对没起到什么帮助。他试图把这件事抛在脑后。一年半后，他在网上漫无目的地浏览。
And I saw on Facebook people posting the trailer for the movie and being like, hey, go see this movie if it's in a theater near you because it's made by Rebecca Adelman, and she's great, and so funny. And I saw those popping up. And then I just had this moment where I was like, oh, the moment is here. And that was when I was filled with the most dread.
我在Facebook上看到有人发布了那部电影的预告片，说，嘿，如果附近的影院有放映就去看这部电影，因为它是丽贝卡·阿德尔曼拍的，她很棒，很有趣。我看到了那些帖子。然后我突然有了那种感觉：噢，时刻到了。那一刻我充满了恐惧。
What were those thoughts?
当时在想什么？
For me I was-- the thing I was the most afraid of is that the movie would portray me accurately.
对我来说，我最害怕的是电影会准确地刻画我。
Will's candid about his flaws, admits he was kind of a dud as a husband. Will and Rebecca met when she was 23. He was just 19. They were together for eight years, married for almost five. During that time he was mostly unemployed, though he eventually started doing part time work, walking dogs and house sitting. He did some stand-up, but not very often. Mostly he'd spend his time--
威尔对自己性格上的瑕疵很坦率，承认他作为丈夫确实不怎么样。威尔和丽贝卡相遇时她23岁，他才19岁。他们在一起八年，结婚近五年。在那期间，他大多处于失业状态，尽管他后来开始做兼职，遛狗和看房子。他也做过单口喜剧，但次数不多。他大部分时间都在——
Like refreshing Gawker, or I was playing Playstation, or I was like, literally just sitting there thinking about how I should be doing something. I wasn't really-- I had no actual goals and I wasn't striving for anything. That was, like, I think the defining quality that, like, ended our marriage.
比如刷Gawker，或者玩Playstation，或者我就真的坐在那里思考我应该做点什么。我没——我没有任何实际目标，也没有为任何事情奋斗。我认为那是结束我们婚姻的决定性特质。
Because she was the ambitious one and disciplined. She wanted to be a TV writer. She'd wake up early to work on scripts and when he watched the trailer, that was in it.
因为她是那个有野心且自律的人。她想成为电视编剧。她会早起写剧本，当他看预告片时，这些都包含在里面。
And she is the harder worker and, like, actually wants things.
她是更努力工作的人，确实想要实现目标。
I got the job.
我得到那份工作了。
What?
什么？
They just hired me as a writer.
他们刚刚聘请我做编剧。
Woo! My wife is the smartest woman in the world! Look how awesome she is! We're going to be rich. Can I get a Nintendo?
呜！我的妻子是世界上最聪明的女人！看她多棒！我们要发财了。我可以买个任天堂吗？
Seeing the trailer made it so much worse. Now he realized the film would probably return him to some very painful times he'd rather not relive, like the way their marriage ended.
看到预告片让情况变得更糟了。现在他意识到这部电影可能会把他带回一些他不想重温的痛苦时光，比如他们婚姻结束的方式。
To me at the time, it really felt like it came out of nowhere. She got home from work, and she just had, like, a very, very strange-- like, you know the way people will start-- like, they'll be like, so. And then she sat me down, and she was just telling me about how she was unhappy in the relationship, and she had been for a long time. And then me being like, gee, I just-- I don't know why this hasn't-- why none of this has come up before.
当时对我来说，感觉真的像凭空发生的一样。她从工作中回家，有着非常非常奇怪的表情——你知道人们开始说话的方式，他们会说，那么……然后她让我坐下，告诉我她在关系中很不快乐，而且已经很久了。而我却像，天哪，我只是——不知道为什么这些都没有——为什么这些都没有提前提出来。
I just loved her and I didn't-- I really felt like we should try and give it another chance. And she was like, mm, I don't know. And at a certain point we were talking and I was like, who are we fooling here? It really seems like you're done, and this is done. And she was like, OK.
我只是爱她，而且我没有——我真的觉得我们应该尝试再给彼此一个机会。她说，嗯，我不知道。在谈话的某个时刻，我说，我们在骗谁呢？看来你真的结束了，这段关系完了。她说，好吧。
Will moved out after just a week, started crashing on friends' couches. He was devastated, didn't understand what went wrong. And there were other scenes from their lives that he'd hate to see in a movie.
威尔在一周后搬走了，开始借宿在朋友家的沙发上。他很崩溃，不明白哪里出了问题。还有其他来自他们生活的场景，他讨厌在电影里看到。
I'm sure there will be conversations with like, her mom, or her sister, and her friends. I don't know if they were like, come on, girl, you got to dump him. Those will probably be the toughest parts, because I imagine those will be things that will be very based in reality.
我肯定会有她和她妈妈，或者她妹妹，或者她朋友的对话。我不知道他们是否会说，得了吧，姑娘，你得甩了他。那可能会是最艰难的部分，因为我想那些将会是非常基于现实的内容。
The film, which is called Paper Year, came out in early 2018. It's got 71% on Rotten Tomatoes. Critics comment on how authentic the couple's love coming undone feels. For a while, Will couldn't bring himself to see it but a month ago he suggested we watch it together, and I was into the idea. I'm going through a divorce right now.
这部名为《纸婚年》（Paper Year）的电影于2018年初上映。在烂番茄网站上获得了71%的好评。影评人评论说这对夫妻爱情的消亡看起来有多真实。有一段时间，威尔无法强迫自己去看，但一个月前他建议我们一起看，我对此很感兴趣。我现在正在经历离婚。
It's a very strange time of life. I go on a lot of long walks. I stopped watching television for a year so I wouldn't avoid my feelings. All I read are self-help books. And when I go to parties, I corner divorced people and badger them for details about what this was like for them and how they got through it.
这是一段非常奇怪的人生阶段。我走很多很长的路。我停止看电视一年，这样我就不会逃避我的感受。我读的所有东西都是自助书籍。每当我去参加聚会时，我就会把离婚的人拉到角落，追问他们那段经历是什么样的，以及他们是如何挺过来的。
Divorce is like my own personal disaster porn. So, watching a movie about a divorce with the person who it happened to, it's all I want to do. And Will thought it would make it easier for him to see it for the first time.
离婚就像是我个人的“灾难色情片”。所以，与当事人一起看一部关于离婚的电影，这就是我想要做的。威尔觉得这会让他第一次看电影变得更容易。
Like, this is a better way to view it, with other people than just, like, it's 3:00 in the morning, I'm alone, the lights are off, I've gotten up in secret and I'm like, watching it in the middle of the night so I can just deny having ever seen it if I want to.
就像，这是一种比那种在凌晨3点，我独自一人，关着灯，偷偷起床，在深夜看电影，如果我想的话甚至可以否认看过它，更好的观看方式。
Hi, puppy!
嗨，小狗！
I met Will where he was staying. He's dog sitting at a sleek Los Angeles home overlooking a canyon-- Furry throw pillows, an open layout, pomegranate and lemon trees framing your view of the valley, all really expensive. Will is on high alert. Anytime I move anything, he is careful to put it back exactly where it had been.
我遇见威尔的地方是他住的地方。他正在洛杉矶一处俯瞰峡谷的时尚住宅里看狗——毛茸茸的枕头、开放式布局、石榴和柠檬树勾勒出山谷的景色，一切都很昂贵。威尔处于高度戒备状态。每当我移动任何东西，他都会小心翼翼地把它放回原位。
OK, are we ready?
好了，准备好了吗？
Sure.
当然。
That was such a ominous laugh.
那笑声真是不祥。
The movie opens with the couple, Dan and Franny, getting married in a courthouse, which Will and Rebecca also did. Dan lifts Franny and carries her out. The couple starts out really in love-- having lots of sex, laughing, kissing in bed.
电影以那对夫妇丹和弗兰妮在法院结婚开场，这正是威尔和丽贝卡所做的事。丹抱起弗兰妮跑了出去。这对夫妇开始时非常相爱——拥有很多性生活，大笑，在床上接吻。
Is your rash gone?
你的皮疹好了吗？
Yeah.
好了。
Really?
真的？
Yeah.
真的。
I never had a rash. There's no rash. I don't know what they're talking about.
我从来没长过皮疹。根本没有皮疹。我不知道他们在说什么。
The guy's job in the film? Dog sitter.
电影里男主的工作是什么？遛狗。
He's quite the rascal, aren't you? Yeah, he's a good boy.
他真是个捣蛋鬼，不是吗？没错，他是个好孩子。
Wait, can I just point out the dog that you're house sitting in this movie is literally the same breed of dog that is sitting under the table right now?
等等，我可以指出吗？你在这部电影里看护的那只狗，简直就是现在坐在桌子底下的那只狗的同一个品种。
Yeah. It's like a Jack Russell chihuahua mix that he's dog sitting and I am also dog sitting a Jack Russell chihuahua mix.
是的。就像他看护的是一只杰克罗素梗犬和吉娃娃的混种，而我也正在看护一只杰克罗素梗犬和吉娃娃的混种。
In fact, the house in the film where Dan and Franny do their dog sitting is a lot like the house Will and I are sitting in at this very moment-- similar layout and decor, same view.
事实上，电影中丹和弗兰妮看狗的房子，和威尔和我现在坐的房子非常像——类似的布局和装饰，同样的风景。
This comes from--
这来自——
No, I want to finish this.
不，我想看完它。
In another scene, Franny is sitting at her computer working on a script. Dan is trying to get her attention.
在另一个场景中，弗兰妮坐在电脑前写剧本。丹试图引起她的注意。
It's just you writing for your dumb job. Come on, swim. Swim.
这只是你为你那份傻工作写的东西。得了吧，游泳去。游泳。
Stop.
停。
(SIGHS)
（叹气）
Later.
等会儿吧。
The real life version of this would actually play out a little differently-- less fun and more sad. Will says he'd do everything he could to get out of her way when she was working.
现实生活中的版本其实会略有不同——没那么有趣，更悲伤。威尔说，当她工作时，他会尽一切努力离她远远的。
I would just, like, disappear. Like, I'd like, wheel the TV into the bedroom and watch it in there just so it wouldn't be distracting.
我就会，就像，消失。比如我会把电视机推到卧室里，在那里看，免得干扰她。
The movie, which I'll admit I'm the target audience for, I liked it. Marriage made Franny unhappy in the same way it made me unhappy, like my life had ended. I spent so much time thinking about whether or not I wanted to be with my husband, but I couldn't tell him that. So we had nothing to talk about, because if he asked me what I was thinking, the real answer would have been, I'm not sure if I love you anymore.
这部电影，我承认我是目标受众，我很喜欢它。婚姻让弗兰妮不快乐的方式和我经历的不快乐一样，就像我的生活结束了一样。我花了很多时间思考我是否想和我的丈夫在一起，但我无法告诉他。所以我们无话可说，因为如果他问我在想什么，真正的答案会是，我不确定我是否还爱你。
The scene that Will feared of Franny confiding in her mom and friends about all her husband's terrible qualities, and everyone's saying what they really think of him-- that never happens. There's no scene where anyone badmouths him. None at all. No one tells anyone to dump the loser. Instead, what happens is much more interesting. Late in the film, Franny sits down to talk to her mom about her marriage. In the scene, she's trying to convince herself to stay with him.
威尔害怕的那个场景——弗兰妮向她妈妈和朋友倾诉她丈夫的所有糟糕品质，每个人都在说他们对他的真实看法——那从未发生过。根本没有那个场景。一点都没有。没有人告诉任何人甩掉那个失败者。相反，发生的事情要有趣得多。电影快结束时，弗兰妮坐下来和她妈妈谈论她的婚姻。在那个场景中，她试图说服自己留在他身边。
I'm fine. I'm fine. Everything's fine.
我很好。我很好。一切都很好。
Will sits forward in his seat. The day his marriage fell apart, Will came home and Rebecca was on the couch crying. She said she'd been talking to her mom but he never knew what their conversation was about. He felt like he was getting to see it now. In the scene, Franny, played by Eve Hewson, talks to her mom, played by Andie MacDowell.
威尔在座位上向前靠了靠。他婚姻破裂的那天，威尔回家，丽贝卡正在沙发上哭。她说她一直在和她妈妈谈话，但他从不知道谈话内容是什么。他觉得现在能看到了。在那个场景中，由伊芙·休森饰演的弗兰妮与由安迪·麦克道威尔饰演的妈妈交谈。
Maybe it's just like, the first year of marriage is the hardest, you know, like that old saying? And like, in a few years we'll look back on it and laugh.
也许就像那样，婚姻的第一年是最难的，你知道吗，像那句老话？几年后我们回首往事会大笑。
Baby, look at me. That saying's bullshit. The first year should be your best. It wasn't none of us will stick around, because it only gets harder. Much harder.
宝贝，看着我。那句话是废话。第一年应该是你们最好的时光。如果连这都没做到，我们没人会留下来，因为只会变得更难。难得多。
It's-- it's just like seeing how upset she is, that like, sucks. She like, felt really bad. Like, this is just a bad feeling for someone to have to go through.
这——这就像看到她有多难过，真的很糟糕。她，感觉真的很不好。这对于一个人来说真的是一种糟糕的感受。
You're seeing how hard it was for her.
你看到了这对她来说有多难。
Well, it's just-- I don't think I was incorrect to focus on my own struggles during the whole process of splitting up. But it did kind of prevent me from like, thinking about hers as well. I just didn't have as much of an appreciation for like, the difficulty of it, the like, misery that goes into that choice.
嗯，这只是——我不认为我在整个分手过程中只关注自己的挣扎是错误的。但这确实让我没能思考她的感受。我只是没有充分体会到其中的困难，那种导致这一决定的痛苦。
It also is a little bit of a relief that it was hard for her. If it had been very easy for her to end things, I would've felt like such absolute trash. If just one day she'd come home and been like, you know what? Not for me. Bye, pal.
这对她来说也很艰难，这在某种程度上是一种解脱。如果她要结束这一切很容易，我会觉得自己像个绝对的垃圾。如果她某天回家说，你知道吗？不适合我。再见，老兄。
But that's the story you've kind of been telling yourself.
但那正是你一直告诉自己的故事。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
For years, Will had been telling himself the same version of their breakup, something he'd sandpapered down into this. Rebecca got her big break and then she dumped him out of the blue. He was heartbroken, she was happy and thriving. Moving on was easy for her. But watching this, it came flooding back-- at least a year, maybe more, when Rebecca was sad before their breakup. It was like time traveling through all this pain that he'd deleted from his memory.
多年来，威尔一直告诉自己同样的版本，那是他磨平了棱角后的版本。丽贝卡取得了重大突破，然后她毫无征兆地甩了他。他心碎了，她却很快乐且蒸蒸日上。对他来说，丽贝卡向前看很容易。但看着这一切，回忆像潮水般涌回——至少一年，也许更久，丽贝卡在分手前一直很悲伤。就像穿越了他记忆中删掉的所有痛苦时光。
We asked Rebecca to come talk about her movie with Will. She met us at the house where Will was house sitting. It's a little awkward. They talk about the weather and traffic. In the six years since their marriage ended, they've never had a conversation about it. And for her, understandably, this did not seem like the best way to begin one, by talking about her movie.
我们请丽贝卡来谈谈她关于威尔的电影。她在那栋威尔正在看护的房子里见了我们。有点尴尬。他们聊了聊天气和交通。在婚姻结束后的六年里，他们从未谈论过这段经历。而且对于她来说，可以理解，这似乎不是开启对话的最好方式，通过谈论她的电影。
You know it has-- and I mean this in a certain sense, it has nothing to do with Will. It's its own movie. And it's not a documentary. So I kind of object to the idea that we're going to read into this movie and we're going to use it as some kind of, like, secret code to understand this real life relationship that existed.
你知道，这有——我是从某种意义上说的，它与威尔无关。这是它自己的电影。它不是纪录片。所以我反对我们去解读这部电影，并把它当作某种秘密代码来理解这种现实生活中存在的真实关系的观点。
But also, I feel like, the way you're saying it, it's like, oh, I just made a movie. It was just a movie. Why are you reading into this movie? But I feel like there are-- it's more specifically related to an experience that you had.
但也，我觉得，你这样说，就好像，噢，我只是拍了一部电影。那只是一部电影。你为什么要在电影里寻找隐喻？但我觉得有——它更具体地与你有过的经历有关。
Sure. But I'm not, you know-- I'm not the first person to do such a thing.
当然。但我不是，你知道——我不是第一个做这种事的人。
He had to be a dog walker.
他得是个遛狗的人。
Well, but--
嗯，但是——
I said that's why I knew. I was like, he's going to dog sit and he's going to have no ambition.
我说这就是我为什么知道。我说，他会去遛狗，而且会毫无野心。
Yeah. I also, I guess I always thought of that character as not someone without ambition, but someone who is afraid. And I'm not-- that's not me, like, looking at you going like, that's really who you are.
是的。我猜我也总是认为那个角色不是一个没有野心的人，而是一个恐惧的人。我不是——那不是我看着你，心想，那真的就是你。
Will tells Rebecca what he told me, how the most emotional part of the movie was seeing her side of things, how hard it was for her to decide to break apart and then to finally do it.
威尔告诉丽贝卡他告诉我的内容，关于电影中最感人的部分是如何看到她的角度，她决定分手再最终付诸行动是多么困难。
It felt bad because it was just her trying to justify not ending it, or trying to convince herself, like, it'll get better. And that was like, a very emotional thing for me, and the most affecting part of the movie, like hard to watch.
这感觉很糟糕，因为那只是她试图证明不结束它，或者是试图说服自己，一切会好起来的。那对我来说是一种非常情绪化的事情，也是电影中最令人触动的部分，很难看下去。
Is it because it reminded you of that last sort of big conversation we had that was emotional?
是因为它让你想起了我们那次情绪化的最后一次重大谈话吗？
It felt bad because it reminded me of like, you having to do, yourself, kind of all of the recognizing of the problems in the relationship. I just hadn't ever considered the like, journey to coming to that point, and that conclusion, and like, how difficult it is to do that. That's clear, right? That make sense?
这感觉很糟糕，因为它让我回忆起你必须自己去认识关系中的问题。我从来没有考虑过通往那一结论的旅程，以及那样做有多困难。这很清楚，对吧？有意义吗？
I think so. I mean, is this now like, the part of the show where we just talk about our break up? Do you want me to respond?
我想是吧。我是说，这现在是节目中我们谈论我们分手的部分吗？你想让我回应吗？
Yeah, I mean, I don't really want to get into it, but that was a really tough period, and those were really, kind of like, weirdly dark, confusing times. And I think that's why I wrote this. It wasn't like I was trying to write this so you would understand something.
是的，我是说，我不想卷入其中，但那是一段非常艰难的时期，那些时光确实奇怪地阴暗、令人困惑。我想这就是我写这个的原因。并不是因为我想写这个让你理解什么。
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
I was doing it so that I could understand something.
我写它是为了让我自己能够理解什么。
I feel like-- so, I mean, I obviously relate to this because I'm going through a divorce. I left my husband a year ago and--
我觉得——所以我，我的意思是，我显然能体会这一点，因为我正在经历离婚。我一年前离开了我丈夫，而且——
Oh, more personal info. My marriage seems really similar to theirs. My husband was mostly unemployed. I was the one who is working all the time. Neither of us were happy and I had to be the one to call
噢，更多的个人信息。我的婚姻似乎和他们的很像。我丈夫大部分时间处于失业状态。我是那个一直在工作的人。我们都不快乐，我是那个必须开口的人——
--I sort of knew. And I have to say, I wish he would give me credit, you know? Like, it was really awful and hard and heartbreaking and I was tormented by it and it was the hardest decision I've ever made.
——我有点知道。而且我必须说，我希望他能给我一些认可，你知道吗？那真的很糟糕、艰难、令人心碎，我被它折磨着，那是我做过的最艰难的决定。
And I would just-- like, this is my dream realization that my partner could ever have, which is to say, like, oh, my god. It was hard for you, too. Like, are you getting that? Are you getting-- am I like, projecting? No, I mean--
而且我只会——这就像是我伴侣可能实现的梦想，那就是说，噢，天哪。这对你来说也很难。就像，你明白吗？你明白吗——我是在投影吗？不，我的意思是——
It's just, we've been broken up for how long now?
我们已经分手多久了？
It's over six years.
已经超过六年了。
Yeah. I mean, and I haven't been spending much of that time going, thinking, oh, I hope Will understands my perspective some day. You know, I think I've just-- I think it's really nice that maybe there is some kind of mutual middle ground that we're seeing it from. But I think that I've just-- it was OK for me to let Will have his own path through it.
是的。我是说，我并没有花很多时间去想，噢，我希望威尔有一天能理解我的视角。你知道，我觉得我只是——我觉得也许有一种我们都能看到的互惠中间地带很好。但我认为我只是——让威尔以他自己的方式走出来对我来说是可以的。
Will had a story of how things ended that was cemented in his mind, and without the film he would have gone on thinking it, cherry picking the moments that made him feel the worst. Rebecca says if you want your ex to understand your breakup, the best way probably isn't to make a movie about it. It's way too much work and money and the most likely outcome is that they'll hate you for it.
威尔心中对于结束的方式有着坚定的故事，没有那部电影，他会继续那样认为，挑选那些让他感觉最糟糕的时刻。丽贝卡说，如果你想让你的前任理解你们的分手，最好的方式大概不是拍一部关于它的电影。这需要太多的工作和金钱，最可能的结果是他们会因此恨你。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our show was produced today by Elna Baker. People who worked on the show include Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Stephanie Foo, Damien Gray, Michelle Harris, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Anna Martin, Miki Meeks, Stone Nelson, Nadia Raymond, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们节目今天由埃尔娜·贝克制作。参与节目的工作人员包括本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、斯蒂芬妮·富、达米安·格雷、米歇尔·哈里斯、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、塞斯·林德、安娜·马丁、米基·米克斯、斯通·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷蒙德、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。我们的执行编辑是苏珊·伯顿。
Special thanks today Bud Meyers and Alvin Melathe. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia.
今天特别感谢巴德·迈耶斯和阿尔文·梅拉斯。我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600集的档案。本节目由公共广播交换中心PRX提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, I was short on money for lunch the other day. And I said, Torey, you have any cash? Do you have cash? He got really defensive.
你知道，我前几天午饭钱不够。我问，托雷，你有现金吗？你有现金吗？他表现得非常有戒心。
I never had a rash. There's no rash. I don't know what they're talking about.
我从来没长过皮疹。根本没有皮疹。我不知道他们在说什么。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories at This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《This American Life》，会有更多故事。